welcome to this video playing aqaba in
the house again and the sony the
statistics function is telling me that i
have a 61 squad against the sky despite
the fact that our ratings are relatively
close okay the classical Steinitz
variation III this is the modern main
line of this opening as I learned in
this this book but i'll go attended
tildes and my theory really is coming to
to an end after a three i only have had
a brief look at all this in the book and
i need to rely on my general
understanding of french positions which
is probably not great I have done I have
played the French for years on and off
and really stopped after some disastrous
games one of the games actually is the
main game in the opening book opening
for white according to Anand the serious
buyer likes under Calif one where he
suggests a wide repertoire based on 1.e4
and this is constructed loosely along
the lines of the opening rapper 12 now
former world champion vishy anand but
the main game of this part of the french
is actually a game of mind that are lost
against grandmaster Nabu in the dutch
league and this was kind of a 20-game a
20 move game where was duly mated
in a very very direct fashion it was
just completely destroyed I wanted to
play g6 actually no I am able to it's a
bit ugly but it's how does he ever make
progress here with the bishop on b5 I'm
stopping the c-4 move I don't think I
have anything I don't have anything to
fear in this position
and they wonder is it possible to do
something actually maybe if i double on
the sea foam i can maybe take at some
stage intend to enter on non SI for if
he takes with the poem you okay is
taking himself but this doesn't really
very me I'm thinking about putting
putting a rope here and then play maybe
H form or g5 in interesting Oh whoopsie
form no not good let's take check and go
here and tending to to open up here now
if I a good man let's let's consider g5
maybe maybe g5g five and h4 something
like that okay if he takes that play
rookie for and grab the if I upon this
should be good for black so he's not
going for that but what about this snow
maybe h4 try to get rid of the
weaknesses iam
the night then rupee for maybe f6 okay
wait wait wait not so quick maybe yeah I
can do that now it's it's okay I
threatened to take and rookie for
winning the winning the pole so he needs
to take check and he has two weaknesses
to worry about f4 and c3 it's not so
easy to play for white I threaten king
of five and I win win one of the pawns
ok so is going for counter play if i
take look h7 to be seven problem
hmm
maybe a formal would cover that if he
goes rook h4 fy5 okay so this didn't
this didn't help okay I need to take it
there's no no real alternative to that
okay so the question is how to continue
now d for evening sir is possible takes
rook check kingi for a three bed rock
p.m. he always gets there look of two
blunders the rook shouldn't do that
okay i try to push the pawns not not one
hundred percent sure how to what's the
best here a checker I can just I can
just protect it
okay let's see i can go deform i try to
try to keep the poem takes rook takes
King III up to five but this is very
passive chatham want to play in such a
passive way
okay I cannot manage without the King
can you form Andrew gave to this must be
right I think so it's not a material
issue ok so here and then rook a to
check yeah I think this is good taking
taking the porn so that I have the
airport check ok now i cannot play three
of course hmm ok that's not ideal of
course but probably I didn't see
anything else it's probably just a drone
maybe maybe I have some chances
check check check check
who gave five check
check
check-check time boarding check check
check wait for Phase I would know it's a
win well very tense end game but i'm not
i'm not entirely sure i mean if you
should be able to draw gathers this end
game that can be deceptive but it's
clear that term only black has some some
slight chances because my rook is just
more active maybe you should play
something like that this reduces me to
have six here I have something rookie
for so maybe even better okay here rook
takes a force a good news this is that
ok this is why rookie falls better first
interesting I can always take but after
Luke takes I can take me five and
hereafter take some I I cannot take I
mean I can but it's it's not it's not a
win so after Luke takes I need to
retreat and then he always has this idea
so that i can probably not switch here
at least not switch with the idea to win
the game okay so what we got this end
game
I tried this okay and now I took the
question is if I played it correctly
five looks good utilizing the pawns
check on TM camera computer wants to
play a rogue f to check king d3 and then
the ID wants to go to aid a two and take
a three I wanted to activate the king
this looked very logical to me check but
he had this funny idea can deform yeah
the [ __ ] [ __ ] gives us as a straight win
that even see so so minus eight so it
probably sees the pong promotion already
coming d3 is stronger here it's ok i
think what i did i think it shot when I
really check check check now rupee five
is a bit so check how this is a draw
actually no this is not you think this
is the draw ah this is a funny idea this
is a mate mate and this is this is jack
petchey I didn't see that this is a
problem ok so this is why I need to at
this point playbook b5 and this is
really easy just pushing has no way to
prevent it captain will have to check he
allowed that it so it's a will check
check no after 82 it's a draw yeah I
didn't have so I didn't have the time
really well this is already at all mmm I
was pretty optimistic here with the
sting cut off but maybe I don't really
managed to to to get the B file back
yeah hard to say I only had 20 seconds
myself alright thanks for watching